vamos a resolver este problema de
volumen dice un tanque de agua tiene 12
pies de alto 5 pies de largo y 9 pies de
ancho una caja sólida de metal con 7
pies de alto 4 pies de largo y 8 pies de
ancho ya sea el fondo del tanque el
tanque se llena con agua cuál es el
volumen del agua en el tanque ok déjame
hacer un dibujo para que entendamos que
nos están preguntando bah entonces aquí
voy a poner el tanque este es uno de los
lados va a quedar más o menos así a lo
mejor no es el mejor dibujo del tanque o
de un tanque verdad que que pueda
existir en el mundo pero bueno nada más
queremos darnos una idea general de cómo
se ve el tanque entonces ahí ya tenemos
más o menos el tanque imagínatelo en
tres dimensiones y vamos a pensar que es
como una pecera entonces tiene estos
lados transparentes y podemos ver qué
sucede en el interior hoy voy a pintar
voy a pintar que podemos ver también los
otros lados pero los voy a pintar así
punteados
entonces es un tanque transparente muy
bien y nos dicen que dentro de este
tanque hay una caja sólida de metal
déjame dibujarla la voy a hacer más o
menos así más o menos así otra vez a lo
mejor no queda mucho a escala pero no
importa nada más queremos darnos una
idea de de qué está sucediendo aquí
entonces la caja más o menos sería más o
menos sería algo como de este estilo
ok ahí tenemos ya casi la caja ok y
además de esto bueno nos dicen las
dimensiones tanto del tanque como de la
caja nos dije nos dicen que el tanque
tiene 12 pies de alto 12 pies 5 pies de
largo 5 pies y 9 pies de ancho 9 pies de
ancho y que esta caja de aquí tiene 7
pies de alto 7 pies de alto 4 pies de
largo 4 pies y 8 pies de ancho 8 pies de
ancho y bueno ya teniendo todo esto
empezamos a llenar el tanque con agua
aquí empezamos a echar agua entonces se
empieza a llenar no sé imagínate que más
o menos por ahí quede el nivel del agua
bueno si hay que llenarlo completito
pero imagínate que por el momento se ve
como algo de este estilo entonces ahí
tenemos el agua por ahí queda la
superficie del agua más o menos vamos
haciendo eso pero existe llenar todo
todo el tanque va entonces seguimos
llenando llenando llenando hasta que
llegamos al tope y a partir de eso nos
preguntan
nos preguntan cuál es el volumen del
agua en el tanque
bueno pues ese volumen que le voy a
llamar ve a que sería igual lo que
tenemos que hacer es encontrar el
volumen del tanque y a eso restar el
volumen de esta caja de aquí por qué por
esta caja no va a pasar nada de agua
entonces el volumen sería igual al
volumen del tanque que podemos calcular
multiplicando sus dimensiones 12 pies 12
pies por 5 pies por 9 pies 9 pies
si quieres a esto de aquí le pongo que
es el el volumen del tanque va volumen
del tanque tanque ya eso tenemos que
restar el volumen de esta caja el
volumen de la caja azul que sería de 7
pies 7 pies menos 4 pies no perdón por
porque estamos sacando un volumen verdad
entonces sería 7 pies por
cuatro pies cuatro pies por ocho pies
por 88 pies muy bien estoy acá es el
volumen de la caja volumen
d
jaja
muy bien entonces eso sería el volumen
del agua que cabe vamos a hacer las
cuentas el volumen sería igual a 12 por
5 60 60 por 9 es 540 aquí nos quedaría
540 pies cúbicos pies cúbicos ya eso
tenemos que restar a ver 7 por 4 mejor
lo voy a hacer así 4 por 8 es 32 32 por
77 por 321 210 más 14 menos 224 224 pies
cúbicos pies cúbicos
si hice la multiplicación bien mejor lo
hago con calma vale no sea que me haya
equivocado y haya cometido un error
tonto entonces 4 por 8 es 32 32 y eso lo
voy a multiplicar por siete por 7 y 7
por 12 14 llevamos 17 por 3 21 y una que
llevamos 22 a jan 224 muy bien así que
ya nada más tenemos que hacer la resta
el volumen sería igual a 540 menos 224 y
eso es igual a 316
a 10 pies cúbicos muy bien entonces 316
pies cúbicos es la cantidad de agua que
cabe en el tanque considerando que en
nada de esa agua va va a estar dentro de
esta caja azul